Der Vesuv ist einer der gefährlichsten Vulkane
weltweit.
Doch an ihn grenzt ein noch explosiveres Gebiet:
Die “Phlegräischen Felder” ein Supervulkan.
Ein britisches Forschungsteam hat jetzt herausgefunden,
dass dieser Supervulkan deutlich häufiger
ausbricht als man bislang angenommen hatte.
Steht hier womöglich ein Ausbruch kurz bevor?
In den vergangenen Jahren hatte es jedenfalls
verschiedene Hinweise darauf gegeben.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Am Vesuv rumort es.
In direkter Nachbarschaft liegen die “Phlegräischen
Felder”.
Ein Gebiet in der Nähe von Neapel, das von
Eruptionsherden durchzogen ist und somit geprägt
ist durch starke vulkanische Aktivität.
Eine Katastrophe, denn die Region dort ist
wirklich dicht bevölkert!
Die Menschen dort sitzen also auf einem Pulverfass.
Und genau deswegen haben Forschungsteams weltweit
die Entwicklungen dort ganz genau im Blick.
So auch Fachleute von der Universität Oxford,
die jetzt herausgefunden haben, dass der Vulkan
namens “Campi Flegrei” wohl häufiger
in die Luft fliegt als man bislang angenommen
hatte.
Und das bedeutet auch, dass die Intervalle,
in denen der Supervulkan aktiv wird deutlich
verkürzt sind.
Zu dieser Erkenntnis kamen die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler, weil sie bei Bohrungen
in Neapel und nordöstlich der Caldera entsprechende
Ablagerungen gefunden hatten.
Vulkanische Glase nämlich - ein Material,
das in der Fachsprache auch als Masseria-del-Monte-Tuff
bezeichnet wird.
Bei der Analyse stellte sich heraus, dass
dieses Material aufgrund seiner chemischen
Zusammensetzung zu einer Eruption vor 29.000
Jahren passt.
Diese Puzzleteil hatte bislang in dem großen
Rätsel um Europas Supervulkan gefehlt.
Denn entsprechende Ablagerungen waren zwar
schon in der Vergangenheit in See- und Meeressedimenten
im Mittelmeerraum aufgespürt worden.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “„Diese
vulkanische Ascheschicht, Y-3-Tephra genannt,
bedeckte mehr als 150.0000 Quadratkilometer
des Mittelmeerraums”.
Doch bislang war nicht klar, welchem Vulkan
sie zugeordnet werden muss.
Obwohl die Analyse dieser Aschen- und Tuffschicht
zeigte, dass es gewisse Ähnlichkeiten mit
dem Auswurf der Phlegräischen Felder gibt.
Doch im direkten Umfeld des Vulkans konnten
trotz intensiver Suche bislang keine Hinweise
auf eine Eruption zu diesem Zeitpunkt gefunden
werden.
Und so gingen Experten bis jetzt davon aus,
dass es in dem Hoch-Risikogebiet der “Phlegräischen
Felder” vor 40.000 und vor 15.000 Jahren
zu Eruptionen kam.
Bei der ersten handelte es sich wohl um einen
extrem gewaltigen Ausbruch, der ganz Europa
mit Asche bedeckte.
Die Asche wurde sogar bis nach Russland geschleudert.
Die Super-Eruption vor 15.000 Jahren war im
Vergleich dazu wohl schwächer; hatte es dennoch
in sich.
Doch die aktuelle Studie zeigt jetzt eindeutig,
dass auch dazwischen wohl keine Ruhe herrschte,
sondern es auch zwischen diesen beiden Ausbrüchen
heftig gekracht hatte.
Dazu der beteiligte Forscher Paul Albert:
“Die Verteilung und das Volumen der Ablagerungen
sprechen dafür, dass der Masseria del Monte
Tuff aus einem Ausbruch der Stärke 6,6 stammt”.
Vergleichbar also mit der Eruption der Phlegräischen
Felder vor rund 15.000 Jahren.
Und auch hier hat der Supervulkan wohl dafür
gesorgt, dass es über dem gesamten Mittelmeer-Raum
zu einem Asche-Regen kam.
Diese Stärke ist zudem auch vergleichbar
mit dem Ausbruchs des indonesischen Vulkans
“Tambora” im Jahr 1815.
Dadurch starben nicht nur mehrere zehntausend
Menschen, sondern es gab auch Folgen für
das Klima.
Nicht umsonst wird das Jahr 1816 als das “Jahr
ohne Sommer” bezeichnet.
Diese neuen Erkenntnisse aus Oxford sind von
großer Bedeutung.
Denn jetzt steht fest, dass der “Campi Flegrei”
in den vergangenen 40.000 Jahren eben nicht
nur zweimal, sondern dreimal explodiert ist.
Wie gesagt befindet sich dieser Feuerberg
in der Nähe einer der dicht besiedelten Regionen
Europas.
Und so wären Millionen Menschen in Gefahr.
Zudem häufen sich in der jüngeren Vergangenheit
die Hinweise, dass der Vulkan aktiv ist und
sich regt.
Untersuchungen hatten unter anderem festgestellt,
dass in der letzten Zeit vermehrt Gas austritt
und sich wohl auch vermehrt Magma im Untergrund
ansammelt.
So hatte beispielsweise ein Forschungsteam
aus der Schweiz 2018 festgehalten, dass der
nächste große Ausbruch wohl schon bald bevorstehen
könnte.
Darauf kamen die Fachleute, weil sie eine
Art Langzeit-Magma-Modell erstellt hatten.
Dies deutet wohl an, dass sich die Bedingungen
im Magma-System verändert haben müssen und
sich dort nun eine möglicherweise gigantische
Menge an glühender flüssiger Gesteinsmase
ansammelt.
Im Jahr 2016 hatten Fachleute aus London Muster
von Bodenhebungen in der Nähe des Supervulkans
hingewiesen, die wohl dafür sprechen, dass
man an einem kritischen Punkt sei.
Welche Folgen ein Ausbruch für die Region
und auch für ganz Europa haben könnte, ist
umstritten.
Die Region würde höchstwahrscheinlich von
einem Ascheregen begraben und den Himmel über
Italien verdunkeln.
Das Gaspartikelgemisch in der Luft würde
zahlreiche Todesopfer fordern; ganze Städte
würden unbewohnbar und die Vulkanasche würde
den Flugverkehr lahmlegen.
Katastrophe durch Supervulkan - Hat die NASA
die Lösung?
AAA würde ich mal sagen anklicken, Anschaue,
abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!